[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wir auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport ein schönen guten Tag und
das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
Festnahme beim Bundesnachrichtendienst
ein Mitarbeiter sitzt in
Untersuchungshaft er soll
Staatsgeheimnisse an Russland verraten
haben
[Applaus]
die Ukraine hält ihre Stellungen und
wird niemals kapitulieren viel Jubel im
US-Kongress für die Rede des
ukrainischen Präsidenten
und corona-welle erfasst China experten
rechnen mit vielen vielen Toten die
Regierung verharmlost die Gefahr
[Musik]
wir beginnen mit einem schweren Verdacht
ein Mitarbeiter des
Bundesnachrichtendienstes wurde in
Berlin festgenommen er soll für Russland
spioniert haben der Generalbundesanwalt
ermittelt wegen Landesverrats den
BND-Mitarbeiter wird vorgeworfen
Staatsgeheimnisse an einen russischen
Nachrichtendienst übermittelt zu haben
weitere Einzelheiten will der
Auslandsgeheimdienst vorerst nicht
preisgeben Begründung Russland sei ein
Akteur mit dessen Skrupellosigkeit und
Gewaltbereitschaft man rechnen müsse
fragen wir Theo call in Berlin warum ist
der BND so zurückhaltend mit seinen
Informationen
nun eine der schlüssigsten Erklärungen
dürfte sein dass man der russischen
Seite keinerlei Hinweise geben will wie
und von wem man auf den möglichen
Doppelagenten aufmerksam gemacht wurde
denn jede weitere Informationen könnte
ja den russischen Geheimdiensten dann
helfen beispielsweise deutsche Quellen
oder auch Zuträger in Russland ausfindig
zu machen der BND-Präsident hat es heute
sehr deutlich formuliert als Gefahr er
sagte mit Russland habe man es auf der
Gegenseite mit einem Akteur zu tun mit
dessen Skrupellosigkeit und
Gewaltbereitschaft zu rechten sei jedes
Detail könne dem Gegner helfen
Deutschland zu schaden so jedenfalls der
Chef des Auslandsgeheimdienstes
was bedeutet dieser Fall für die
Bundesregierung
Carsten L ist ja wegen des Verdachts auf
Landesverrat festgenommen worden und das
ist deutlich mehr als nur der Verdacht
auf Spionage er habe ohne dass das näher
beschrieben wurde ein
staatsgeheimnisverrat und das heißt er
gehörte offenbar zu einem kleinen Kreis
von Menschen die hochsensible
Informationen gehabt haben müssen die
die Sicherheit des Landes Gefährten
könnten und die er offensichtlich an
einen russischen Geheimdienst
weitergegeben hat die
Sicherheitsbehörden waren seit langem
vor zunehmender russischer Spionage und
auch vor einer hohen Zahl an
ansprechbaren Personen in einer Zeit in
der Deutschland ja die Ukraine im Krieg
gegen Russland unterstützt dürfte das
also noch problematischer sein als ich
schon vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung
aus Berlin
die russische Tyrannei hat keine
Kontrolle mehr über uns das sagte der
ukrainische Präsident vor dem
amerikanischen Kongress ein umjubelter
Besuch selenskys beim größten
Unterstützer zur rechten Zeit ab Januar
haben die Republikaner die Mehrheit im
Repräsentantenhaus und könnten dann die
Finanzhilfen für die Ukraine kürzen
Claudia Bates berichtet aus Washington
Begrüßung mit Standing Ovations
Präsident selenski wird im Kongress
gefeiert als Held der Freiheit er dankt
für die massive amerikanische
Unterstützung die wichtig sei um nicht
nur Widerstand zu leisten sondern den
Krieg tatsächlich an einen Wendepunkt zu
bringen
Gelder sind keine Almosen sie sind eine
Investition in die globale Sicherheit
und die Demokratie sie werden
verantwortungsvoll eingesetzt
die Ukraine werde sich niemals ergeben
verkündet er in Anlehnung an den
britischen kriegsprämie Winston
Churchill 1941 starke Worte denn hier
sollen heute als Teil des Haushalts fürs
nächste Jahr weitere 45 Milliarden
Dollar an Hilfe für die Ukraine
verabschiedet werden
nach der Rede verlangen einige
Abgeordnete beider Parteien sogar mehr
Unterstützung für die Ukraine sollte das
Haushaltsgesetz scheitern dann wegen
anderer umstrittener Punkte für die
Ukraine aber wäre das dramatisch
umso wichtiger das Präsident beiden
zuvor weitere zwei Milliarden Dollar an
Militärhilfe zugesagt hat darunter das
hochmoderne Patriot Flugabwehrsystem
wir unterstützen Sie so lange wie es
nötig ist was sie tun und erreicht haben
ist nicht nur bedeutsam für die Ukraine
sondern für die ganze Welt
am Ende seines Besuchs überreicht
Präsident selensky der
parlamentssprecherin eine ukrainische
Flagge mit den Unterschriften von
frontkämpfern denn ihr Schicksal liegt
auch in den Händen Amerikas das klare
Signal von hier an den russischen
Präsidenten Putin die USA werden mit
ihrer militärischen Macht verhindern
dass er den Krieg gewinnen kann
Verhandlungen werde es nur geben wenn
die Freiheit der Ukraine und ihre
territoriale Integrität
wiederhergestellt sind
nach Israel sieben Wochen nach der Wahl
steht die neue Regierungskoalition von
Benjamin netanjaro erstmals werden drei
rechtsextreme Parteien beteiligt sein
dazu religiöse Fundamentalisten einige
Regierungsmitglieder sind wie Netanyahu
selbst wegen Korruption oder
Steuerhinterziehung angeklagt oder
verurteilt die generalstaatsanwältin
Israels warnt angesichts der
Regierungspläne vor einer Gefahr für die
Demokratie aus Tel Aviv Thomas Reichert
ich habe es geschafft gesagt wenn ihr
mir kurz vor Mitternacht kurz vor Ablauf
der Frist Israel Staatspräsidenten
anruft der tanja hat nach seinen Weißig
Anfang November lange gebraucht um alle
Koalitionspartner mit ins Boot zu holen
für seine Rückkehr an die Macht seit der
einen hohen Preis an Nationalisten und
ultra-
wir haben große Hoffnungen dass die
Regierung eine wirklich konservative
rechtsgerichtete sein wird
die Menschen sind ziemlich verängstigt
keiner weiß in welche Richtung es geht
es ist die Ruhe vor dem Sturm
mit ittermar wenn wir wird ein
Nationalist Minister für innere
Sicherheit dennoch im Oktober bei
Auseinandersetzungen selbst die Pistole
zog und die Polizei aufforderte auf
Steine werfen der Araber zu schießen
ihre history er war in der Vergangenheit
ein Provokateur und eine rücksichtslose
Person des öffentlichen Lebens
hoffentlich wird er versuchen mit den
Herausforderungen für Israel gut
umzugehen und im Amt kein Provokateur
mehr zu sein
läuft ein Korruptionsverfahren seine
Koalition wie die Unabhängigkeit der
Justiz einschränken Änderungen im
Strafrecht Durchsetzen von denen könnt
ihr auch profitieren
Natalie aus neue Regierung steht so weit
rechts wie kaum eine je zuvor in der
Geschichte Israels und viele befürchten
dass sie mit ihren Zielen nicht nur die
Demokratie in Israel sondern auch die
Lage in der Region auf eine schwere
Probe stellen wird die neue Regierung
muss nun noch von Israels Parlament der
Knete bestätigt werden
nach Deutschland das Wahlalter runter
auf 16 und eine Bundestagswahl alle fünf
Jahre statt vier dafür macht sich
Bundestagspräsidentin Bass stark eine
längere Legislaturperiode wäre auch für
den Bundestag gut so ihre Einschätzung
und wenn Jugendliche schon ab 16
wahlberechtigt wären dann wachse die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie auch später
zur Wahl gingen meint die
Bundestagspräsidentin
die Weihnachtsbotschaft des CDU
landratsaus Bautzen in Sachsen schlägt
hohe Wellen seine Aussagen zu
Asylbewerbern sein unchristlich und
rassistisch so der Vorwurf auch die
Bundes-
Bautzens Landrat udovics hat die CDU aus
ihrem vorweihnachtsfrieden gerissen weil
er seine Weihnachtsansprache mit der
Botschaft verknüpfte wo er
Schutzsuchende unterbringen will und wo
nicht in Turnhallen zum Beispiel
das ist nicht unser Absicht den Sport ob
nun den Schul- oder auch den
Freizeitsport jetzt für diese
Asylpolitik bluten zu lassen der
cdu-koalitionspartner in Sachsen zeigt
sich entsetzt über eine Sprache die wie
ein Brandbeschleuniger wirken können
finde das einen ungeheuren Vorgang eine
als Weihnachtsansprache getarnte
Hassrede ist das Gegenteil von dem was
wir benötigen und ich erwarte hier
wirklich ohne klare Abgrenzung in
sozialen Medien fand wie just Zuspruch
sah sich aber auch heftiger Kritik
ausgesetzt auch die CDU Bundesspitze
reagierte also Haltung ist klar und
deutlich wir wollen innerhalb einer
solchen Sprache nicht über die
Unterbringung von geflüchteten sprechen
und deswegen haben wir uns auch von der
Formulierung distanziert zum Hintergrund
der Kreistag Bautzen hat es sich
kürzlich gegen eine zentrale Wohnstätte
für geflüchtete in Hoyerswerda
ausgesprochen doch auch zur
Unterbringung in Wohnungen findet der
Landrat deutlicher Worte
ich will auch nicht den Weg verfolgen
dass wir Menschen die zu uns kommen die
unsere Kultur nicht kennen die unsere
Regularien nicht kennen jetzt hier in
Mehrfamilienhäusern in freistehende
Wohnung unterzubringen und dafür ich
glaube die Gefährdung des sozialen
Friedens in Kauf zu nehmen eine
Distanzierung von der weihnachtsrede ist
vom sächsischen Ministerpräsidenten
nicht zu hören auch nicht von deren
Duktus ich will ihn einmal auch deutlich
sagen das ist ja hier ganz
offensichtlich auch eine Verkürzung gibt
und ein Video was völlig aus dem Kontext
gerissen ist und ich glaube dass man die
Dinge im gesamten sehen muss und Udo
Witcher selbst fühlt sich missverstanden
allerdings sei er bis fünften ersten im
Urlaub und wünscht gesegnete Weihnachten
das Ende der nullco wird Politik in
China hat eine corona-welle losgetreten
die zu einem Tsunami werden könnte
warnen Experten und auch die
Einschätzung eines Krankenhauses in
Shanghai klingt dramatisch die
Klinikleitung geht davon aus dass sich
mittlerweile schon 5,4 Millionen
Einwohner Shanghais mit Corona infiziert
haben Chinas offizielle Zahlen dagegen
sprechen von gerade mal 3.100
Neuinfektionen landesweit binnen eines
Tages Elisabeth Schmidt
auf Knien fleht dieser Mann eine
Krankenschwester um Hilfe an doch sie
weist ihn ab Videos wie dieses kursieren
gerade im Netz überprüfen lassen Sie
sich nicht doch auch das Staatsfernsehen
zeigt mittlerweile Bilder völlig
überfüllter Kliniken
normalerweise kommen bei uns hundert
Patienten pro Tag in die Notaufnahme
momentan sind es 400 die meisten sind
schon älter haben Vorerkrankungen und
befinden sich in einem wirklich
kritischen Zustand die winterwelle
trifft das chinesische Gesundheitssystem
mit voller Wucht gut 138.000
Intensivbetten stehen laut
Gesundheitskommission bereit pro Kopf
etwa halb so viele wie in Deutschland
die Impfkampagne geht nur schleppend
voran die Weltgesundheitsorganisation
ist besorgt
die Hälfte aller Menschen über 60 Jahren
in China sind gewusstet das ist einfach
nicht das Schutzlevel dass ein
bevölkerungsreiches Land wie China
benötigt bleibt die Frage ob in den
nächsten ein zwei Wochen mehr geimpft
werden können
technischen kapiton in the coming week
laut offizieller Statistik starben diese
Woche in China nur sieben Menschen an
kovit 19 doch immer mehr Krematorien
melden dass sie ausgelastet sind dieser
Bestatter hier in Peking bestätigte dem
ZDF Einäscherung erst wieder Mitte
Januar möglich
es ist gut möglich dass sich halb China
ansteckt die Zahl eine Million Tote
kursiert ich glaube es könnten diesen
Winter sogar zwei Millionen werden china
hat es versäumt seine Impfstoffe an
Omegon anzupassen
Ende Januar stehen auch noch die
Feierlichkeiten zum chinesischen neuer
an der Kampf gegen das Virus er ist ein
Wettlauf gegen die Zeit
was kommt auf China zu und drohen
gefährliche Mutationen darüber spricht
heute live unter anderem mit einem
Virologen um 19 Uhr in der ZDF heute App
und auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
in der weltweiten Energiekrise setzt
Japan wieder verstärkt auf Atomkraft die
Regierung beschloss das alte Mailer
länger als 60 Jahre laufen dürfen
außerdem sollen moderne Reaktoren gebaut
werden nach der Katastrophe von
Fukushima 2011 hatte Tokio alle Anlagen
heruntergefahren nur wenige gingen
wieder ans Netz nun also die Kehrtwende
das rohstoffarme japan will ähnlich wie
Deutschland seine Abhängigkeit von Gas-
ein weiterer Schritt Richtung Steinzeit
so nennt Außenministerin baerbock heute
das was in Afghanistan gerade passiert
die radikalislamischen Taliban schränken
die Frauenrechte weiter ein frauen
dürfen jetzt auch keine Universitäten
mehr besuchen die Taliban wie sind die
internationale Kritik zurück das Verbot
sein notwendig damit sich die
Geschlechter nicht mischten Alexandra
Vacano berichtet
gleiche Rechte und Freiheit für alle
rufen sie eigentlich wollten die
Studentinnen vor der kabula
uni-protestieren doch von dort hätten
sie die Sicherheitskräfte vertrieben
[Musik]
die Frauen wurden geschlagen und
ausgepeitscht sogar die Frauen bei den
Sicherheitskräften haben mitgemacht wir
sind weggelaufen einige wurden verhaftet
ich weiß nicht was passieren wird
nicht mehr zur Uni dürfen die
Studentinnen sagen hier gebe es kein
Leben mehr für Frauen ihre Zukunft
verbaut von den Taliban diese
Entscheidung kommt ganz offensichtlich
vom ultra-konservativen Kern der tale
warenführung die bestehen aus dem
talerbahnchef und einigen religiösen
geistlichen digitale Bahnführer sagen
dass entspricht dem islamischen Recht
der Scharia wir treffen die 20-Jährige
nasira die in Kabul Pharmazie studiert
und sich hier in einer Privatschule auf
die anstehenden Prüfung vorbereitet
hatte jetzt das
schon als die Schulen geschlossen wurden
hat die internationale Gemeinschaft
nichts gemacht und jetzt wird wieder
nichts passieren für unsere Zukunft
besteht keine Hoffnung mehr
auch ihr Lehrer fassungslos
es war schockierend als ich das gestern
hörte und hat mich fertig gemacht das
ist keine Entscheidung für den Moment
sondern hat Folgen für die Zukunft
unserer Gesellschaft
Frauen sollen aus dem öffentlichen Leben
verdrängt und weltliche Gesetze nach und
nach abgeschafft werden so Experten
[Musik]
zu einem sehr harten islamischen Staat
man könnte sagen einem Gottesstaat die
Politik der Taliban vor allem für
Afghanistans Frauen ein Rückschlag
alle Jahre wieder ist in Spanien schon
vor den Festtagen Bescherung bei der
Weihnachtslotterie el Gordo die Gewinne
werden singend vorgetragen
[Musik]
nicht jeder Ton ein Treffer dafür jede
gezogene Zahl insgesamt werden 2,5
Milliarden Euro verteilt dann der
Hauptpreis
und Jubel im Publikum dort sitzt
zufällig eine Gewinnerin eine
arbeitslose Einwanderin erhält 400.000
Euro auch sonst im Land gab es Geldregen
und weitere Gesangseinlagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du singst jetzt auch hast du gesagt
ins Spiel geht es auch bei der Dart WM
in
London die Nase vor zum dritten Mal
dabei und zum dritten Mal die dritte
Runde erreicht Gabriel Klemens der
letztes Jahr sogar als erster deutscher
ins Achtelfinale Einzug the German giant
nennen sie ihn mit einem souverän
Auftritt gestern Abend im Hexenkessel
des Elli
das war gigantisch sie kennen ihn sie
lieben ihn den Deutschen Riesen Gabriel
Clemens längs etabliert in der Hochburg
des Darts im Duell gegen den ihren
William O'Connor gelangen ihm immer
wieder nervenstarke Abschlüsse seine
erste 180 ließ nicht lange auf sich
warten der deutsche gewann den ersten
Satz knapp mit drei
auch den zweiten Satz entschied Clemens
für sich mit drei perfekt sitzenden Satz
Darts
als der deutsche im dritten Satz dann
schnellen Führung ging konnte nur noch
mit dem Kopfschütteln der 39-Jährige
hochkonzentriert und präzise schloss den
Durchgang mit einem starken 132er Finish
Gabriel Clemens gewann das Match mit 3:0
nach Sätzen und steht im Runde 3 der
Darts WM
Niklas Bachleitner hat den deutschen
beim letzten Weltcup des Jahres die
vierte Podestplatzierung der Saison
beschert der 26-Jährige Freestyler im
blauen Leibchen er kämpfte mit
italienischen Innichen einen starken
dritten Platz für Bachleitner war es
nach 2021 das zweite weltkaputton in
seiner Karriere ein Sieg fehlt dem
26-Jährigen aber noch den holten sich
heute Rees Hoden aus Kanada vor dem
japanerius
zur Fußball Champions League der Frauen
da hat Bayern München gestern Abend
Benfica Lissabon bezwungen durch einen
Doppelpack von Clara Bühl nach einem
Traumpass von Georgia stanway ihr erster
Treffer in der 51 Minute ja und dann in
der 75 Minute war es wieder die
Engländerin wieder mit einem perfekten
Zuspiel klarer Bühl zum 2:0 entstand
punktgleich mit Barcelona die Bayern als
Gruppen zweite im Viertelfinale
erfolgreicher Jahresabschluss für die
Münchnerin dankeschön gerne haben Sie
schon einen Weihnachtsbaum vielleicht
selbst geschlagen im Wald ist ja für
viele eine schöne Alternative auch Biber
gehen gerne mal einen Baum holen
nicht irgendeinen
und zum schönsten gerne auch den
schönsten Teil
nach einer gewissen Fleißarbeit muss
noch die Transportaufgabe gelöst werden
alles wie bei uns nur im biberbaum im
Biberbau wird der Baum ziemlich sicher
nicht hübsch aufgestellt ihr schöne
aufgefressen der Baum im Biberbau das
ist auch eine kleine Herausforderung das
Wetter ist sogar nicht weihnachtlich der
Deutsche Wetterdienst waren vor
ergiebigem Dauerregen in Teilen von
Baden-Württemberg mehr dazu hatte ich
gleich Katja horneffer das heute journal
mit Marietta Slomka um fünf nach zehn
danke für Ihr Interesse einen schönen
Abend noch und bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend tief hongia verhagelt uns
das weiße Weihnachtsfest denn von Westen
bleibt es einfach mildregnerisch und
windig schon heute hat es ja kräftig
geregnet und in der Nacht regnet es
weiter im Südwestwind bleibt es sehr
mild die Temperaturen sinken meist auf
12 bis 5 Grad und einzig im Nordosten
oder auch in Ostbayern wird es etwas
kälter an diesen Werten ändert sich
morgen über Tag nur wenig uns erwarten
Höchstwerte zwischen vier Grad an der
Ostsee und 15 Grad am Oberrhein der
Regen sieht weiter nach Nordosten und es
gibt stürmische Bühnen Sturmböen und im
Schwarzwald in den Gipfel lagen sogar
orkanartige Sturmböen bis 100 km pro
Stunde anders sieht's in Norddeutschland
aus da zeigt sich morgen häufiger die
Sonne und es gibt diesen ganz ergiebigen
Dauerregen besonders in den Stau lagen
im Schwarzwald und im Allgäu innerhalb
von 24 bis 36 Stunden können dort bis zu
100 Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter
zusammenkommen kleinere welche und
Flüsse werden also anschwellen und auch
sonst besonders hier in der Mitte regnet
das kräftig
Heiligabend kann sich vielleicht in
Schleswig-Holstein oder in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern am Vormittag mal
eine kleine Schneeflocke unter den Regen
mischen danach ist es dafür zu Milch
guten Abend